il ya eu une visée me et puis il y a des
gens comme été testés positifs sauf que
les chiffres on est des chiens mais au
courant jamais précisé donc aujourd'hui
objet de faire sortir vous êtes en train
de dire c'est qu'ils pouvaient pas faire
sortir les différents mais que la
flambée du coville était déjà et elle
date d'il ya plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois exane dont ils ont
attendu la fin des jeux paralympiques
pour sortir les chiens savent qu'elles
voulaient pas polluer les jeux
olympiques l'un des passants affolés les
ailettes c'est fou donc ça veut dire
quoi te dire que là en ce moment l
immunité collective à n'a pas marché en
chine non il est jamais été marcher à
l'achat mais il y avait surtout et ça
n'aurait bon quand même bayonne 0 des
trucs voilà parce que la premier quart
en atp en tout cas de promotion souvenez
exactement il ya deux ans jour pour jour
c'est awad humide 11 millions de
personnes est confiné le jour au
lendemain ses sens et puis à plusieurs
villes sur la carte on faisait pas très
complète la pige à vis
à vis la route est confiné à partie des
8 mars en plein jeux paralympiques
d'accord donc et il est aujourd'hui
shenzhen du nord et du sud tilly c'est
là une récompense dont l'ami le centre
le plus le plus important c'est 39
millions habitants shenzhen au sud de la
chine c'est la ville mika mégapole ya
tous les grands sites industriels et
nouvelles technologies comme brown comme
ali baba ils sont pas et là bas giresse
millions de personnes ils ont confiné le
jour au lendemain dans mes soeurs et
donc là ça veut dire que quand se
fait-il qu'en chine il reconfirme à
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu est-ce qu
il ya un nouveau variant il ya une
flambée qu'est ce qui se passe c'est la
même mariant la flambée s'est dit les
chiffres qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas au
courant parce que par exemple shanghai
où je vis le chiffre des décès il est
important aussi non ils annoncent très
peu de tessé d'accord ça un autre mais
vos questions en plus vrai ça finissant
même héros confine à quartier et surtout
par par neil par exemple et qu'on
finisse et dire que travailler à la
maison tous les cols sont fermés
jean-marc d'où les transports sont
fermer tous les transports en termes ils
sont fermées par exemple à pékin il ya
tout ce grand autoroute qui vont lier
avec et d'autres villes complètement
fermé l'autoroute est fermée
donc il ya une sorte fermeture est on et
puis deuxième chose c'est là c'est la
teste massive obligatoire c'est les
choses et c'est impensable enfants
seulement rester chez eux en attendant
ou s'appelle tel et l'immeuble tel
numéro beauté santé faire la tête alors
et pendant trois jours aux quatre jours
ou fait trois fois la teste alors bien
plus rien du tout en cette quartier cvs
l'ipc mais est ce qu on a des raisons de
s'inquiéter tu rates quand on entend ça
en chine tam a dit sérieux nous raconte
pas de blague c'est la stratégie de la
chine depuis le début c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que la chine a éternué en
janvier 2020 et si le monde entier qui
s'est enrhumé sauf que ça c'était en
2020 maintenant on a compris que ce
virus situer les plus fragiles et c'est
toujours terrible qui est des morts mais
tu sais les plus fragiles ses 85 ans la
médiane d'âge c'est un taux de mortalité
de 0 07 % il faut le rappeler à chaque
fois alors c'est sûr que 0 0 7% sur 1
milliard 4 en chine ça commence à faire
numériquement pas mal de mort mais le
variant ya pas un nouveau variant c'est
pas un mystérieux virus chinois on est
toujours sur le variant omicron c'est
toujours alors le ba1 ou le béa 2 mais
en tout cas on est sur un virus qui
globalement un virus qui est devenu plus
faible et donc ya aucune raison de faire
ce que fait la chine et je vais même
plus loin plus vous confiné qui est
comme une mesure qui est inefficace
moyenâgeuse tout ce que vous voulez plus
vous allez retardé l'immunité collective
et donc plus vous allez avoir votre
bombe à retardement qui va exploser dans
un deuxième temps et c'est un peu le
problème de la chine tous ces pays qui
ont confiné il n'y a pas d'immunité
collective les plus fragiles sont encore
là et ils vont forcément être contaminés
et il va y avoir malheureusement des
formes graves alors que chez nous et
bien on a une immunité qui s'est diffusé
tamarins on va reparler dans un instant
mais vous êtes vous est confiante pour
la france on ce
oui parce que ça fait deux ans qu en vue
d'une telle manière
je pense comme beaucoup d'autres on en
peut parce que là nous lé là nous on va
tout lâcher la saillie donc là est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle flambée
des karma tu voulais dire quelque chose
non parce que le professeur a ou avait
dit il y aura forcément une nouvelle
vague mais en général une nouvelle un
nouveau variant mais à chaque fois
qu'ils aient un nouveau variant il est
plus contagieux mais moins mortel est ce
que c'est le cas en ce sens les gars
c'est pas très dense et l'évolution de
toutes les épidémies de toute la
virologie ce père que globalement c'est
des virus pourquoi il ya des variantes
parce que le variant on sait il rentre
dans une population il ya le vaccin où
il ya des gens immunisés donc il va
chercher à contourner pour chercher à
contourner il va se multiplier et se
faire des erreurs dans sa multiplication
d'où son affaiblissement donc il devient
plus contagieux mais moins grave en
termes moins mortelle alors ça c'est la
généralité après on n'est pas à l'abri
d'un variant etc sauf que qui serait
plus dangereux plus contagieux etc c'est
pas le cas c'est pas le cas dans
l'histoire des virus après on va voir en
tout cas omicron c'était plutôt moi
j'avais dit en décembre c'est la chance
génialement de cette épidémie et ça
s'est avéré vrai alors juste tamarins en
chine dès ce qui est des gens qui sont
anti vaccins il y en a certains il ya
des récalcitrants s'en doutait de
personnes âgées ou les personnes qui
croient pas trop les vaccins chinois
mais il y aura jamais on en entendra
jamais les manifestations dans la rue ça
mais tous sont opprimés et la barrière
forcément il ya des gens qui veut passer
vacciner parce qu'il fait pas confiance
à le vaccin chine ils ont vu que les
vaccins chinois en chine en chine à
weehawken possibilité d'avoir autre
chose
justement ce à propos de ce vaccin on a
dit que le vaccin chinois et efficace
qu'à 35% est ce que c'est vrai ou pas
oui on sait qu'ils les vaccins n'ont pas
la même efficacité après attention les
efficacités elles ont été mesurées sur
des variants qui n'existaient pas c'est
à dire que le variant de houran au
départ qui était la souche initial c'est
là dessus qu'on était fabriquer les
vaccins donc c'est là dessus qu'on a eu
les taux d'efficacité deux ans après on
a des variants omicron on a eu delta on
sait que l'efficacité de tous les
vaccins y compris arn messager est plus
faible je regardais juste avant de venir
un papier scientifique dans nature qui
est quand même une grande revue
scientifique on sait que la quatrième
dose le booster par exemple sur une
étude israélienne le booster sur omicron
et très peu efficaces il est efficace
mais très peu longtemps que l'oncle à
casquero met en cause la stratégie de
vaccination et de re re re vaccination
oui oui mais ce qui est important quand
on sait que la chine n'aurait aucun
intérêt à confiner c'est ça ruine le
pays ça fait baisser le tarif est le
fait en plus en général par dont il
communique pas sur les bons chiffes donc
le fait que eux confirme c'est quand
même très à l'aise désolé
de communication et stratégie
ce qui se passe en chine c'est vraiment
ça râle quand il commence à accumuler
compte c'était déjà connus comme unique
sur dix millions c'est qu'on est déjà
sans dire énormément ils sont toujours
en avance je me rappelle quand il avait
le wattman on a eu le baladeur
bas je me rappelle alors je m'inquiète
pas parce que moi je suis pas sur la
communication ou soit de la politique ou
sur des enjeux géopolitiques comme
madame vient bien de dire mais
uniquement sur des enjeux et
virologiques et quand je regardais
virologiquement 10 mais il confirme
pascal rome qui confine parce que la
peur ça fonctionne on sait très bien que
c'est pas du tout de même régime
politique en chine que chez nous et
l'abbr est une manière probablement
docteur king 2009 je rappelle gérald ce
qu elle adore
mine de rien c'est vrai que comme a dit
mathieu ils n'ont aucun intérêt concerts
arts continue à la chine donc c'est que
la situation elle est complètement aller
quand même compris qu'il était mon idole
sa politique intérieure finalement il ya
seul intérêt c'est pouvoir faire des
tests obligatoires
c'est dire qu'ils font les tests trois
fois en dessous seront payants qui joue
rien qui a des personnes quand il était
positif en les isolés on a fait sortir
des jeux en isoler pas mon opinion donc
pendant sur la suivante en quatre temps
joue cette des quartiers est confiné une
fois de plus de contacts n'y a pas plus
de communes met donc la tâche est alors
l'intérêt financier parce qu'ils payent
leur test et ils sont glissés non ces
créatures non c'est gratuit mais ils
veulent pas me tromper depuis deux ans
ils se sont trompés sur la stratégie
zéro coville sa seconde ne pas m'avoir
9,0 commises à ça c'est un virus qu'on
peut pas supprimer la série sera pas
supprimé mais je les mets en
contradiction entre confinement est le
comider sait ô combien j'ai envie
j'avais mes géraldine maillet sur le co
vide un peu sa maman
ça fait toujours du bien les y aller je
peux dire non mais moi j'ai pas peur
parce que j'espère que c'est la bague ou
mikron et comme ils sont dans une
stratégie zéro co vide mais où on l'a
compris à une immunité globale en france
donc on s'en est très bien sorti non moi
j'aurais demandé aux deux parties
pensent que à l'automne on devra se
relaxine et maintenant les âges et les
[ __ ] content je parle où les gens
fragiles ou les gens malades ou les gens
très gros des médias aussi pour les
jeunes à son père que globalement il
faut arrêter de la stratégie on fait des
mesures généralisée pour tout le monde
il est mesure généralisée c'était le
confinement vaccination pour tous etc
pour passer à une stratégie
personnalisée accary donc ça doit gérer
entre le médecin et son patient et donc
si le patient a plus de 80 ans ou plus
de 65 ans est globalement au dessus de
65 ans et bien il ya plus de risques en
dessous 65 ans et puis les gens fragiles
les gens immunodéprimés l'obésité c'est
un facteur de risque majeur mais en tout
cas faut arrêter de prendre des mesures
qui concernent tout le monde il faut
revenir la médecine de bon sens de la
balance bénéfices risques est donc dans
ce cas on est d'accord qu'on est contre
la vaccination obligatoire à partir
d'aujourd'hui la vaccination obligatoire
je pense qu'elle est plus dans le débat
de même que la quatrième dose elle est
plus dans le même temps la vaccination
des enfants non plus face ça n'a pas de
sens quand je parle de balance bénéfice
risque c'est que je donne un médicament
ou un vaccin et je suis provoque et
provoque ce pour les gens fragiles qu'il
faut protéger en revanche les gamins qui
ont participé à la muas l'immunité de
tout le monde qui nous ont protégés les
enfants en étant contaminée il faut pas
aller les vaccinés on sait que
l'immunité naturelle elle est supérieure
elle est plus durable que l'immunité
post vaccinales donc profitons les
gamins plutôt déculpabiliser 1 heure tu
as tué papy mamie profitons du fait
qu'ils ne font pas de maladies graves et
ils vont faire des anti fourrure
notamment des antilles qu'en operate mon
protégé tout le monde générale le même
question d'une spéciale géopolitique
valérie bègue est ce que à terme on aura
affaire à notre vaccin une fois par an
par exemple comme on fait le vaccin de
la grippe et on devra y retourner
régulièrement être parents peut-être
mais encore une fois chez les gens
fragiles le vaccin de la grippe c'est
plus de 65 ans aux femmes enceintes
personnes obèses immunodéprimés ou
insuffisants respiratoires ou rénaux
donc ça veut dire on a le risque de
maladies graves ont fait le vaccin est
peut-être qu'il faudra leur faire
sûrement sachant que attention les
anticorps on sait pas mesurer l'immunité
donc c'est pas parce que vous avez des
anticorps élevé que vous serez l'unité
est élevée on sait pas ça on sait pas le
faire en route on a une question fruits
et légumes 2
bonjour vraiment de rungis non non moi
ça à la question faut-il avoir peur moi
je dis faut-il être inquiet moi je suis
inquiet parce qu'un témoin kg et
inquiète t
inquiète pas trop quel
trajet inquiète parce que là bas quand
ils ont dit on ferme des villes des
villages s'est tout de suite 9 millions
et bien sûr nous on sait pas quand même
c'est tout tu t'enfermes ile de france
pour représenter ccsa donc je me dis ah
non si ça arrive là-bas peut-être que ça
va arriver chez nous et je suis inquiet
parce que je ne veux pas remettre les
masques je ne veux pas ressortir des
passes sanitaires pour aller au
restaurant je ne veux pas qu'on remarque
nos enfants je ne veux pas que nos
enfants passent sept heures du matin
jusqu'à 17 heures le soir avec un masque
je ne veux plus de tout ça donc oui je
suis inquiet nous tout ce que tu veux
plus qu'on va se doter tous
les salariés vie n'est pas le danger et
puis mais la peur est mauvaise pour le
système et musicien est parce que le
stress c'est mauvais pour notre système
immunitaire et depuis deux ans et fait
matraquer avec du stress et je pense
qu'on devrait donner une bonne dose
d'optimisme sur la mara est ce qu'il ya
des raisons d'être inquiet
pour qui tous les français ou pour les
chinois pour les français et pour les
chinois parce que non alors vous laisser
je pense pas parce que les chinois ne se
quittent plus leur tétouan d'accord
finit donc c'est déjà l'heure ils
sortent pas rien en revanche la paire
700 cas c'est une très bonne facture
pour gouverner le pays aussi le temps
plein la tête pas du tout inquiète pas
inquiète alors je fais confiance à notre
gouvernement d'inquiéter ce qu'on a dit
en janvier 2001 quand tu continues comme
et ont pas mis maintenant m et c'est ce
qu'on avait dit on avait dit non c'est
pour eux c'est pas pour nous non
le carré de couronnes à virus cependant
nous on n'essaie pas pour nous alors
certes on s'y retrouve au mois de mars
comme
celle là c'est pas la peine non mais
c'est vrai
oui il a raison au qg de m faut admettre
qu'on a dit pareil on a dit c'est un
surnom moussaka pas non mais là
vraiment à moi je suis d'accord
deux minutes je vous sens pas hyper bon
sur le sujet mathieu non parce que le
jouet d'accueil de clausade c'est non
c'est ça doit alors j'ai un doute ce que
vers la docteure ce que tu vois la vie
parce qu'on sait que sur les enfants
c'est grâce et féminité on sait que sur
les dieux on sait que sur machin vous
savez tout sauf qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
un médecin et même les maires l'un en
face de l'autre vous n'êtes pas du même
avis vous n'avez pas le même avis qui
prouve donc que non vous ne savez pas
maintenant avant de vous le dire à
chaponnay médecins en patinoire qui est
ici mais à s'habiller encore deux trois
semaines on a fait un débat face à un
autre médecin qui était du porto rico
c'est un comédien à porto rico
chico pedro où qu'ils habitent cette
ambiance que la personne de porto
revient au chili ou chine jeudi 6 mai à
paris n'ont qu'à conduire des embauches
non chilien du chili des classiques
et spécialisés virus et que ce n'était
pas d'accord avec vous nature et sa
passe est très tout se perd en mois mais
en fait vous ne savez par ailleurs je
suis plus j'essaie de pas être
péremptoire pas ce que je fais il faut
quand même de l'humanité en médecine la
deuxième chose c'est que je regarde les
faits et les faits c'est quoi c'est la
médiane d'âge des décès ses 85 ans
l'espérance de vie ces quatre-vingt deux
ans et demi en france ça concerne les
plus âgés sont la deuxième chose c'est
quand je regarde le taux de mortalité
les deux 0 0 7% et l'exercice des
données qu'on n'avait pas en janvier ou
en mars 2020 qu'on a maintenant donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il n'est
pas question de relativiser ou de
diminuer l'importance et chaque décès
c'est terrible pour les familles ça veut
juste dire que la peur est très mauvaise
conseillère notamment pour les
gouvernements et ça veut dire que comme
ça concerne les plus fragiles est bon on
protège les plus fragiles et
troisièmement j'allais dire nous tous on
peut tous renforcer notre système est
missionnaire et ça sert à rien de
commencer comment parce que c'est pas ça
qui va nous protéger du virus mais vous
parlez
et alors ici elle règle j'ai une
question docteur alors moi j'ai pas
docteur un
docteur mon père mais moi non oui
si on suit votre raisonnement est ce
qu'on peut considérer qu'il ya des
personnes qui se sont vaccinés pour rien
battre elle poste des bonnes questions
je pense que dans la balance
bénéfice-risque y a des gens qui se
seront vaccinés pour rien oui bien sûr
faire que moi j'ai toujours dit mettre
beaucoup de collègues encore une fois il
ya les médecins jato il ya d'autres
types de messages il ya des gens qui
s'expriment et une minorité agissent
agissante on peut appeler ça comme ça et
puis une majorité de médecins aussi
qu'ils sont dans on va rester sur la
médecine de bon sens d'abord on ne nuit
pas qui est à risque etc ces gens là
qu'il faut vacciner alors après une
stratégie politique il ya le conseil
médical et puis à la stratégie politique
le gouvernement a décidé parce qu'il y
avait un vaccin qu'il fallait vacciner
tout le monde salois bien qu'ils soient
de la quatrième dose on est en train
quand même de revenir et de relève le
pana ses rimes pas mal est ce que je
serai les émissions posant une mauvaise
question bien sûr en maillot est une
émission de merde
[Applaudissements]
des morts des mains et vieux des vieux
des gros des gros hockey très bien et
vous parlait jamais des coûts vie de
longs mois je me suis intéressé un petit
pot problème des copies l'on vous savez
que les copies l'once exit y en a eu des
dizaines de milliers je sais des gens
très jeunes en très bonne santé et vous
en parlez pas ça existe ça ne sais pas
ce que c'est que kovy de long à l'arc le
coc vie de long c'est pas si c'est le
virus qui seraient actives un peu comme
le zone 1 est la varicelle et puis elle
des rues du zona ils seraient actives
est ce que c'est votre système
immunitaire qui va sur réagir par
exemple votre auto immunité les auto
anticorps bref on ne sait pas il ya des
recherches qui sont faites bien sûr
c'est un vrai sujet on sait pas si c'est
aussi une part psychosomatiques ça peut
exister et moi ça me fait beaucoup
penser à une maladie que je connais très
bien y compris à titre personnel il
s'appelle la maladie de lyme et cette
maladie de lyme qui est souvent négligée
etc on s'est passé le système
immunitaire si c'est la bactérie et donc
ça va faire partie des enjeux j'avais de
connaître pas drôle non plus le kobe de
longs mois
g data la maladie de shaikh pendant deux
ans j'ai guéri forcément une question
vous êtes content et
ça marche ça m'a posé beaucoup de
problèmes mais oui gilbert bisse général
moi j'ai à quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas ce soir je vous admire
beaucoup vous êtes ultra compétent mais
là je vous trouve d'un flingue absolue
il nous rassure authentique l'arménie
sûr de vous écouter que vous y prendre
moi je me coupe les
rassurer mais il rassure ils informent
oui mais est-ce que vous n'êtes pas là
bas ridicule
j'ai l'impression de parler aux médias
et à dix neuf provinces en chine le
confiner le maire de la panique là bas
on a l'impression que ça va venir chez
nous et vous vous dites on s'est
peut-être à l'armée un peu trop
finalement c'était pas grand chose on
craint plus rien j'ai l'impression que
excusez moi mais même vous ne croyez pas
vraiment ce que vous êtes venu nous dire
j'ai fait je crois que je dis mais je le
fais parce que dès le premier jour du
confinement j'étais à l'hôpital cochin à
fort en service comme il est c'est donc
globalement depuis deux ans on a ce
recul en à cette expérience et depuis
deux ans il ya aucune nuance possible
que ça soit chez les politiques chez les
médecins sur les plateaux télé on passe
notre temps à être catégorisés soir
assure east soit la remise et la
médecine la médecine c'est de la nuance
il ya des gens à protéger il ya des gens
qui font des formes graves il ya des
gens qui n'ont quasiment aucun risque et
a porté cette nuance là c'est
extrêmement compliqué et pour revenir
dans la digne que des malades sur ce que
tu dis sur le corps
c'est le côté réseau
j'ai un avenir mais qu'est-ce qui me
booster
ce qu'ils veulent
inspiré ça fait partie du soin non tuera
sur east met un rassurant assurément
différent et un fantôme
c'est pas les pardons mais j'avais fait
médecine donc doucement cantonade
aiguë a disséqué de grosses
premières il a fait la gloire de la
première année tous combien de fois il a
fait une fois la première année puis il
est parti comme les autres c'est la
première année de l'école de police et
fait la première année de telle baisse
est
la chance de garder sachant que
les gens vont pas bien on les matraques
de mauvaise nouvelle à un moment donné
il faut être réaliste dans la nuance et
donner des bonnes nouvelles aussi nul
lavalin
fait d'accord si vous voulez vous avez
une cale une question là tu vas contrat
chez toi tu marchais
les bonnes questions mais il est payé ça
s'est su ou pas
par ailleurs et sans rien dire et luc
plamandon la
[Rires]
scène
je vous plais pas là bas jamais donc ce
que je comprends pas c'est qu'au bout de
deux ans on n'a toujours pas compris que
la politique zéro co vidal était
complètement utopiste elle servait à
rien est-ce qu'on peut pas tester pour
une fois une politique zéro restrictions
c'est la fin du cosy partout dans tous
les pays du monde parce que là en france
on dit que c'est la fin des restrictions
c'est pas vrai il ya encore les masques
pour voyager il faut encore des
ddc convient avec la menace au-dessus de
nous d'un nouveau confinement de
nouvelles restrictions à leur nouveau
pass est ce qu'on veut pas dire un jour
à tous les pays du monde le coc vide
c'est terminé et il n'y aura plus jamais
de oui oui
je crois que plus personne pense au
confinement le vrai problème c'est plus
en test et on trouve plus en la voilà
donc un moment donné moi ça fait des
semaines que j faut arrêter testez vous
êtes malade vous mettez un match vous
êtes malade avec des facteurs de risque
vous allez voir votre médecin s'il faut
on vous fait un scanner etc mais ça sert
à rien de faire ces tests comme ça à
tout le monde ça c'est une certitude ce
qui est intéressant est la question et
intelligente parce que quand on regarde
n'a pas l'air comme ça on regarde les
différents pays dans le monde en
fonction de pays très laxiste ou au
contraire très dur en termes de
politique de restriction et c'est le
juge de paix c'est quoi ces les taux de
mortalité ben finalement les taux de
mortalité c'est les mêmes acer que
globalement ça s'appelle l'évolution
naturelle d'un virus et d'une maladie et
quoi que vous fassiez dans cette maladie
elle va évoluer sa sentence pour sa veut
dire que même ceux qui ont rien fait ils
sont par exemple paris que la wii a
regardé il ya ça donne avec notamment
ben vous avez besoin des taux de
mortalité qui sont pas effroyable encore
une fois il faut que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs servir à info gérard
guerrier pas une population beaucoup
plus âgés ou beaucoup plus à risque etc
mais globalement quand vous regardez et
vous faites à population comparable
c'est la marque aux états unis ça a été
une hécatombe parce qu'il ya des taux
d'obésité extrêmement adresse à pourquoi
en afrique qui s'est pas passé grand
chose parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
patients obèses ou deux personnes qui
sont avec des facteurs de risque la même
épidémie dans vincent ça serait une
hécatombe et c'est pour ça je dis dans
le bouquin il faut préparer notre santé
d'art on peut faire quelque chose à
titre collectif et à titre individuel et
sa fenêtre santé et les réflexes de base
c'est quoi les trois trucs pour préparer
notre santé de demain ce intéressante
pour l'activité physique l'alimentation
et pu booster son sixième unitaire je
suis une pme vous êtes faire garder que
c'est ça une histoire d'âge quand je dis
c'est au delà de 65 ans mais c'est plus
l'âge physiologique que l'âge
chronologique coupe est à vous pouvez
avoir 70 balais être en pleine forme je
suis en avoir 50 et être en mauvaise foi
regardez c'est réglé c'est vrai que
gilles tac à mj ville à 35 ans
le
maquis c'est comme une voiture tu peux
avoir une voiture qui a 108 km est battu
mais la clé dans le débat et puis tout
moment une voiture catherine km qui sauf
qu'une base y'a quoi il ya le contrôle
technique est exact que le contrôle
technique chez nous on ne sait non plus
comment va-t-on faire contre le temps
vous avez vu ce qu'il a dit c'est
incroyable s'il ya des fonds c'est à peu
près le même taux partout et les etats
unis c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
cas d'obésité crémont ces foules ce qui
veut dire bah oui c'était long mais ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'on aurait
dû rien faire on aurait mieux fait de le
faire serait été pareil non on pouvait
pas rester sans rien faire mais en tout
cas on abonde en a fait trop moi je
pense qu'on en a fait beaucoup trop je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous et
pourquoi je dis toujours je suis inquiet
ce que l'on se cache toujours sur les
états unis sur l'italie sur israël donc
6e et conflit ont reconduit leur enfin
pas confiné mais si eux ils remettent
les passes et ceir vacciner on vaccinera
aussi israël s'est bien défendu il est
lui resté utile ils sont bien détendu
utilisons les études regardez les études
sur la quatrième ville sainte étude sur
le confinement est jamais remise à
israël qui a été très restrictif ils ont
les mêmes noms pourcentage bien sûr de
décès que d'autres pays qui ont été
moins comme des mots hydra d'atterrir
sur des mesures raisonnables on a
compris qu'on va pas chasser le covin et
qu'il fallait vivre avec et comment vit
avec bamboo pas vivre avec une épée de
damoclès au-dessus de la tête non on va
pas vivre avec un stress permanent sur
la vitesse il faut les arrêter parce que
ça c'est clair que ça sert à rien et ça
serait tout le we mais ça on a
l'impression qu'on a fait tout ça pour
rien est la question que je me pose
c'est si on n'avait rien fait c'est ce
qui aurait eu vraiment des millions
tous les chiffres qu'on avait les
projections qui disait 400 mille cinq
cent mille morts etc ça n'avait pas de
sens donc je dis pas qu'on a fait ça
pour rien de toute façon on mars 2000 en
savait pas ce qui allait arriver et donc
c'était difficile sur facile de faire
après l'histoire mais en janvier février
mars quand ça arrive est difficile de
prendre une autre décision en revanche
après on aurait pu se détendre et
maintenant je pense qu'il est absolument
pas question de penser confinement ou de
penser mesure généralisée personnalisé
oui généraliser non confiné confinement
c'est finalement la n'existera plus vous
pensez en france et ça n'a pas de sens
et moyenâgeux ça n'a pas de sens les
pays qui ont pas confiné ont bien on a
bien vu que ça avait pas été l'hécatombe
toutes les projections des cinq cent
mille morts ferguson en angleterre etc
ils ont même reconnu eux-mêmes que
c'étaient des mesures pour gouverner un
peu par la peur ou en tout cas pour
pousser ou pour favoriser ses compagnons
à l'acceptation session finalement ne
tapez pas comme ça sans nous regardons
mais
c'est déjà bien rappelez vous il ya six
mois où ils ont passé un musée plus
touchées moi c'est ça lui susurrant
c'est toujours touchant
tous les rameurs
lui a rien dit rien ne tombe jamais
arrivé avant
non mais c'est est touchée que la main
vous êtes sensibles
la médecine baisse sensible ça veut dire
quoi
[Musique]
avant qu'il y ait le vaccin pardon s'il
n'y avait pas eu confinement ça aurait
tué toutes les personnes âgées pardon sa
contrepartie
l'envisager c'est toi c'est pas vrai on
tu sais les docteurs il est donc mal
comment j'ai fait la sénateure de tp
tu sais je sais pas je sais que tu sais
pas j'ai plus de chance que tu aimais
pas douter les sauver c'est à dire à
dire comme ça c'est le cowitz aurait tué
tout le monde et c'est à mon avis on
masque les deux vraies causes de cette
crise oc système hospitalier qui dans un
état lamentable un système hospitalier
kelly proximité des réanimations dont
parle ans suffisamment grand nombre eh
bien ça permettrait les personnes âgées
de les hospitaliser de les mettre avec
de l'oxygène et c est de les faire
ressortir de trois jours de m fillon et
des offices à l'air sonné ce duo des
bougnats rire le coc vide quand on le
prend à temps et la deuxième chose qu'on
est en train de masquer ses cette crise
de population c'est notre prévention qui
est déficiente c'est l'obésité qui est
galopante un peu comme et aux etats unis
c'est le mode de vie et ça c'est dommage
parce qu'on pourrait se prendre en main
we would en restant discrète à vous êtes
médecin vous êtes jeunes vous êtes en
bonne santé vous êtes mince vous êtes
vacciné parce que c'est obligatoire est
ce que vous le regrettez regretter quoi
d'être vacciné deux jours aux canaries
je le regrette pas parce qu'encore une
fois quand on a eu le vaccin on n'a pas
de questions on a pensé que c'était la
solution moi j'ai toujours dit le tout
vaccinal c'est une connerie ms que nous
révélons fillon les faits oui bien sûr
chez confiant mais j'ai pas le choix je
soigne en tout cas paris vacciner c'est
toujours
ça me permet de rebondir sur un salon
bar minutes parce que et après par
wisekey et vous soulevez vous sentir
bien connu après ce qui vient de
derrière
ce
qu'il a dit voilà
sinon je me sens pas du tout comme non
merci mr à douala rassurez moi c'est un
bon bah non mariage c'est scandaleux
c'est d'avoir exclu les soignants et les
avoir pointé du doigt en disant si vous
n'êtes pas vacciné vous allez tuer vos
malades parce que c'est faux et je crois
que l'urgence maintenant qu'on sait que
le vaccin c'est pour les plus fragiles
que ça n'empêche pas la contamination
l'urgence ça serait de réintégrer les
soignants maintenant
c'est très fort ce qui vient dire des
gens remettent en cause
la malaisie savard qui est pour les
crèches soignants je pense que c'est le
sytème force qui vient dire c'est pas ça
on a dit aux soignants partez partez ne
restez pas là parce que vous pouvez plus
travailler parce qu'il ya le vide là on
voit bien tout le monde est là on
enlevait le pass vaccinale tout le monde
se baladent là ici il ya plus de masse
et on dit pas aux soignants revenez
travailler on les laisse encore on les
exclut bien pire que ça les gens qui
étaient testés positifs on leur disait
tu vas au boulot face et géraldine le
vaccin n'est pas dangereux mais le
vaccin qui doit être maintenant
réservées aux gens qui en ont vraiment
besoin si la balance bénéfice risque
n'est pas du jour de ce corps non il est
bien très vacciner mais je pense qu'on
peut pas dire mais c'est important de
vous écoute mais moi je suis pro bac et
provoque ce pour les gens qui en ont
besoin c'est à dire les gens à risque il
faut qu'on revienne à quelque chose de
raisonnable ans personnes les tarifs qui
si globalement puisque on a tous senti
je connais deux dossiers médicaux c'est
le seul moment je le connais un peu des
tarifs coupe à risque merci ça se voit
pas mais je sais que 80% des handicaps
par exemple sont un handicap invisible
un pont ce handicap vagal fauteuil
roulant ou obésité et c'est sûr c'est
pas du tout le cas donc ça c'est des
relations individuelles et ce que je
regrette c'est que le secret médical y
en a plus les données médicales y en a
plus il faut revenir là aussi a du bon
sens et à des données médicales qui sont
individuelles entre votre médecin et
vous dans les entreprises en dehors de
chez le co vie de machin away demain on
dira à cet argent ira chez les marins
etc soit il est cher ou encore ben voilà
c'est bon j'ai c'est d'être dans la
nuance j'suis pas anéantir
difficile après 2 en intérieur sur de la
nuance